so how many people here have heard of
quantified self well sometimes who don't
feel good yeah yeah I think we should
call people up and have them talk about
it um so so I want to that's good to
know because I want to know how much how
much background to give but basically
just said before we get started gering
Kevin were two of the core figures in in
starting wired but they that is is
irrelevant in many ways to why you're
here on the stage because what you guys
have cooked up recently is this idea of
quantified self and and just helping
people helping form this community of
people doing this thing so so I want to
like you start by describing what is
quantified self and and how did it start
what is the what is the origin story of
Q s the origin is two parts because we
each came to it with a slightly
different idea my side of it was I run
our site also called cool tools which is
about all neat stuff that you can use to
better your life and I was on a walk
with a doctor friend Alan dr. Ellen
Greene who actually is here and he was
doing an experiment where he was eating
owning organic food for a year and I was
asking him if there were any tools for
testing his own blood to see whether
that was going to show up in his own
blood and we were lamenting the fact
that there wasn't any kind of tools for
tracking your own self and so I thought
it would be a great idea to start
something that would start to track the
kind of tools that you could use to
track your own health and body because
there wasn't a good site that had all
these kinds of things and then at the
same time I had that idea Gary had a
different strand which you can explain
okay well I think part of that for me
relates the fact that when i wrote
stories for wired in the beginning kevin
was my editor and so when I got done
with sort of taking on sort of line
responsibilities at Wired I wrote
stories
for many years but the thing that stuck
in my mind from that experience was
wired sort of built a culture around
technology it was about how we
participated and how we thought about
technology rather than about the
technology itself so i came to kevin at
the same time he was thinking about
tools and I said you know that was
really fun that was sort of two decades
worth of work building cultures around
technologies what are the next questions
that we should ask and we did a kind of
very straightforward exercise we wrote
some technologies up on the board I
remember personal genomics and
geolocation was up there and that kind
of ubiquitous computing and we drew
circle around them and we did an
editorial job and we said what is this
called and if you name something you
have to name why it matters that's what
you're trying to name and we said well
this is stuff is it's sort of about the
language of computing counting rather
than sort of guessing or estimating or
intuitive what kind of quantification
but it's about bringing that all the way
in bringing computing just so close that
it's almost indistinguishable from
yourself so okay quantify itself it's
not the most euphonious name you know
but it's a descriptor it's an accurate
descriptor we said well let's write
about it let's do a blog or something
like that she did wrote a few things and
Kevin so let's let's let's gather some
other people who are thinking about this
we put up a little announcement on
meetup up 30 people came over at your
house and this is the most amazing
moment I thought some guy walks in late
we're having beverages we're about to
introduce ourselves Kevin said okay you
came in lady go first so instead of like
giving a little discourse the guy just
remember yup kingly he just opened his
computer and showed us the most amazing
visualization of every minute of his
time over the past I think year and he
said okay well this is this is who I am
you know i'm going to show you something
about myself rather than tell you
something about myself and that the
light bulb went off i think at that
point that was more interesting than
writing a blog or writing stories it was
sort of capturing the new emergent
culture of technology in the wild among
the people who are actually doing and so
now we have about 70 groups in 15
countries and it
very much a place in a context where we
can get a sense of the human side of
these new tools and and it started about
five years ago is that right 2007 I
think with the first conversation yeah
right so so the the growth of it has
been amazing i mean the community that
has catalyzed surrounded this ideas is
extraordinary i mean you see people you
go to other conferences and they they're
referencing quantified self as if people
should know what what they're talking
about in this conference does but but
what are the what are the kind of core
principles that you guys have devised
out of this so we've been very careful
not to try to define it to carefully
basically we say if you think you're
doing quantified self stuff you are come
show us what you're doing but we
actually doing many many me tips over
and over again for this past five years
some cases almost monthly other cases
not so often another in the bay area was
monthly and we we evolved a set of
heuristics that actually you are really
good for running a little meet up in
terms of understanding what we're trying
to do and I could Gary came up with
these little three little principles
that we use us as kind of the guide for
deciding what we want to talk about and
you can you can you know articulate uh
what did you do how did you do it and
what did you learn so it's very
utilitarian in other words this idea
that this is kind of a tool based view
of the world this this is what the
origin was like hey there's tools there
there's not to hit should be tools and
what are people going to do with these
tools so it wasn't there wasn't any kind
of a larger sense of like um people
should live by numbers that was really
not the it was more like something is
happening with this new ability people
are taking this new ability to measure
everything as Rick was saying not just
us but all these devices all this stuff
we can do something with this what are
some things we can do with it and one of
the things we're going to do with it is
we're going to measure ourselves and so
then that's what the meetings have been
about who's measuring themselves and it
turns out that anything that you can
possibly think of measuring somebody in
the
world is tracking it right now and that
we had a queue asst international
conference just about two months ago and
i said to gary is there anything in the
world that you don't think someone's
tracking right now I had to really think
you really think I said I don't know
anybody I've never heard of anybody
tracking how long their toenails are
growing holy all growling right so that
was the only thing I could come up with
earwax goodness County here now we've
doubled so over I at the US Conference I
said there's nobody in the world
tracking their toe nail growth and in
this guy I am so so so the idea is
really doing that but we didn't get to
have ever like you feed we could get him
to give a talk we would find out how
you're doing it what are you doing what
are you learning and I'm not you know
and in the meantime we've had so many
experiences where we've seen people
developing systems to make it easier for
people to kind of track themselves right
and one of the things that we feel like
we have to contribute to that work that
such important work is you have to give
people a chance to generate the question
not just to find the answer so imagine
the world of computing in which all we
had were menus and the only thing you
could do on the computer was sort of
select from the menu is that somebody
had thought that you might want to you
know do this thing no search boxes you
know no querying you know no ability to
customize this would be a really sad
version yeah of the world yeah and I
think what we're trying to do is try to
provide a context where you can sort of
hear the questions articulate the
questions understand what is this
universe of question asking and maybe
even put yourself into that situation
where you get to kind of state your own
question so so there was a model that
you were going by in the history of
Technology obviously Kevin's an expert
in the history of Technology but this
was one was particularly cute yeah when
we started this we started it again
really launched by having meet up soon
open meet up and we called it the
quantified self user group and the model
was on the homebrew user group in
Berkeley which started at the very dawn
of computers and personal computer
at the time when you basically had to
make your own computer so you couldn't
even buy them this is this was in fact
you know the two steve wozniak and jobs
were kind of involved in this this group
where people were coming showing off the
things they'd made and and figuring out
what they're going to use it for I mean
it was a very similar kind of the state
so we had the model of the user group
and that's how this is being run so far
as show us what you're doing tell us
what you're doing telling us why you're
doing it help us inform each other about
what we can learn from doing it and so
what are what are some of the things I
we talk about toenails but I mean what
are some of the other things that people
are tracking that that are I mean that
people are finding out real things right
there is there's real knowledge being
created here I mean there's so much I
mean in a way we could do this we can
also do this in like QA because I
there's only one way I found to capture
sort of this intense excitement that's
going on in the community right now
which is to kind of get people who are
curious about it to express themselves
about what they're interested in like
what do you want to know about and then
I can almost always put it in contact
with something that's going on in the
community but if you just wanted to make
a list you can make the list in your own
head anything that is trackable is being
tracked heart rate also heart rate
variability as a measure of stress EMG
off the muscles EEG ECG you know steps
of course with digital pedometers
activity level in general sleep phases
of sleep location social relationships
mood really almost anything that people
care about is being turned into
something that can be sort of
interrogated using will using numbers in
the broadest sense and you Gary I
remember talking to you but once and you
you thought the best way to measure for
people to self-evaluate when it's when
there's not an inherent data point when
it's not a blood value or something
right when it's when it's safe for mood
sure that it's a three-point scale is
actually the most useful is that well
this is for me like this is kind of I
think Thomas what you're doing which is
really great is this is the knowledge
exchange we do in the you know in the
community so one question people have is
what's the right scale d is
okay you use one guy uses 100-point
scale to measure his you know his
restiveness and somebody else might say
but wait a second how do you know that
you're 67 today is the same as your 67
yesterday right so there's a lot of work
being done as people sort of share best
practices yeah what I like to offer in
that particular conversation is I think
a three-point scale is terrific because
I think most people in my observation
care about the extremes so three points
scale sort of doesn't give you access to
a lot of nuance in the middle but you
know it's like three is very good and
one is very bad and then there's this
sort of very undef anit to you get to
capture the goods in bed and one of the
things I've seen in people's
self-tracking is cognitive load is very
big problem like even the cognitive load
of saying I have a five-point scale and
I'm not sure whether I should mark this
as a three or a four is enough to kind
of interrupt sort of any some kind of
process of self interrogation you know
so I think this is this is hard
interesting work that's going on in the
community is finding out what really
works to support people tracking
practices so one thing one thing I'm
curious about in this in this
environment is how much of the tracking
should be active and participative like
somebody actually doing it versus this
other world we're going to or a related
world where it's just being monitored or
us how much do you have to be cognizant
of the tracking and I think that is an
inherent tension within this regime
which is that you want to make tracking
as easy as possible so you don't have to
pay attention to it and yet oftentimes
the the the benefit comes from paying
attention to it yeah and so there is
there is a serve balance that we're
doing and one of the ways that I think
will help us get through that is by
having artificial intelligence pay
attention to things so if we go back to
the the model of the homebrew club and
say well the quantified self is still at
the period of being the early computers
and what's interesting about the early
computers is if you look at
how much cultural pennant a penetration
the early computers did was so it was
very little I mean what did in the end
what did personal computers do they were
kind of like word processors that's okay
there was some desktop publishing that's
all right you know music filing it was
actually not very powerful and nothing
really happened with computers until
they were married to the phone until
there until the Internet that's when all
the cultural bending that's when the
force of personal computers came by
themselves they weren't so strong and I
think in the quantified self a lot of
tools we're talking about will have a
limited kind of effect until they are
both brought on to the internet and
brought together and also I think until
we have some kind of AI to give
attention to those things that are the
data that we're accumulating that huge
universe of data that we're just talked
about and then alerting us when the
patterns are there putting on that red
light or giving us a green light and and
so that it's bringing us to attention
when we need to have some attention you
can also God will just it i'm if you
Kevin took us back to this moment when
you couldn't really figure out what a
computer was for in a way and and people
thought all these things are going to be
really amazing you could kind of see it
like in this context with this with an
analog to a group of people like this
you could see it but you couldn't quite
see how it looks so obscure it looked so
difficult it looks so geeky I mean they
were just we were in these conversations
at the time I mean well people are gonna
have to learn to type yeah nobody's
gonna do that like right there if you
don't get rid of the typing you're never
gonna have a widespread computer culture
right you're can't do slow knows that
you know it you can do things faster
just call up somebody rather than exact
they call me some people did learn to
type people of course people learn to
type you know and and of course they
became faster and of course yeah you
know people would say you can't take it
into the bathroom with you or it's too
heavy or when it crashes you can't get
it fixed and but this was not the place
where you had to look really where you
had to look was what is it for you know
if people being driven to use this
because it has real /
so no meaning and when when that happens
these things get fixed right well so one
thing I want to ask because the question
that that you guys get and I get all the
time which is a lot of this numbers a
lot of data makes people very anxious
frightened especially so if it goes into
the calibration of where you want to
alert people but for instance people
with diabetes diabetics have been
monitoring themselves for decades and
they find it to be a great source of
worry and anxiety rather than one of
self-empowerment so so how do you guys
look on teasing out that riddle so I I
think that in the long term will
probably want to bury the quantification
the numbers I i think the quantification
aspect of it in terms of data coming out
will remain but we're horribly I mean
we're just not evolved to deal with
numbers we're not very our brains aren't
really good for dealing with lots of
numbers we don't do statistics very well
we're not really an animal a number
animal and and I think but the data is
going to come in but but what I think
the long-term direction of this is that
we want to we want to use these sensors
that we're talking about to give us new
senses to equip us with new ways to hear
our body so what we're trying to do is
is to listen to our body but we don't
have very good tools ourselves to do
that we can't really hear or see my
glucose levels we can't really measure
our heart arrhythmia we are
imperceptible to those and so what this
is doing is giving us some way to
generate data right now we have to see
them data or charts or curves but I
think in the long term where we're going
to is we want to be able to feel or see
or hear them and I'm thinking of a great
hack in in San Francisco noisebridge how
can these guys took a the digital
compass that you kind of find your phone
they will tell you which way is north
which is generating data and they took a
belt and I took little piezoelectric
vibrators and put it in the belt in in
eight different positions and then the
the belt would vibrate in the north to
action they buried the bear the little
digital companies into the belt so as
the person that the guy was walking
around it was always his belt was always
vibrating Norris and very very quickly
he had an unconscious intuitive sense of
where northwest so that was a new sense
he was he was not he was feeling north
and you want to be able to feel these
new dimensions in that were that these
sensors are going to sense so there's
kind of like getting a telescope or a
stethoscope that would now be able to to
hear your rest level and and in the you
be able to feel it and it's certain
senses and and only when you needed to
and I think that's the long-term destiny
of where we're going with this the
numbers are in the Piedmont right now
but just like the early computers were
you had to build your own you have to
get here no electronics but we can get
we can get beyond that so we can
actually kind of bury those numbers so
at that scale what when it goes to that
level of a new sense that's a bigger
deal that sounds like a bigger deal to
me than just tracking some some basic
biometrics right i mean that that is a
that is a mood of talking about this on
the phone but that's a shift of a much
greater magnitude in terms of in terms
of this scale of human human possibility
or potato what what can you help me help
me understand what that what that shift
represents though well i think when we
say biometrics it's helpful sometimes
they can step back because when we say
biometrics we're sort of adopting a
language in which there's a set of kind
of outputs from the human system that
are understood like its heart rate or
something and then there's a meaning
structure like we know what heart rate
means it's a biometric it means you know
something that you watch because its
diagnostic in a certain way right so so
biometrics are kind of medicalized
numbers that come from the body but what
we see at the quantified self is lots
and lots and lots of signals that people
are such collecting off themselves and
interpreting and making their own
meaning out of biometrics is going to be
a subset of that
right and really the big story is all
the different meanings that people make
from these new senses and these new
signals that the systems are generating
and I think in the end how that looks is
the biomech this kind of gets swamped in
that story and even the biometrics
become something else so you mentioned i
think the diabetes example is really
good what causes so much anxiety in
these diabetes numbers well there's many
different things from the physical
experience to the you know to the
relationship that people have with a
whole medical system of treating their
diabetes but one of the causes of that
stress is attempting to optimize a
number that's extremely difficult to
optimize and is vulnerable to all kinds
of fluctuations in the environment and
in my gross value yeah the glucose value
exactly now in my conversations with
diabetics one of the ways they deal with
that is that they give them self a
little break on the optimization
algorithm and they use it as a signal
that can have more meanings you know and
they take a sort of very personal
high-touch kind of craft approach to
their number rather than as a really
instrumental optimization approach to
their number that's a cultural change
and how we interpret those numbers and a
change in the locus of meaning of these
systems that comes all the way back to
the self and that's where I think we're
headed all right so we have time for a
couple questions quickly just probably
too so one right here yeah we're going
to get you we're going to get you on
microphone so V people in the other
areas can hear this is related to the
guy who figured out where North was with
this belt we've known for a while that
the sundin trot doesn't rise and it
doesn't set but we move but do you think
we can feel the earth but we don't
really feel the earth move so I guess
I'm challenging you know how much you
can internalize anything would you like
to feel the earth we could we could
probably arrange that yeah
I'm challenging that limit like how much
information we already have and whether
we still need those tools yeah I I think
I I I think it's the idea that we can
take something you care about and we can
use numbers to capture it to sense it to
see it in the ways that we can't own
normally and then to to respond to that
and maybe not just respond to the
numbers but actually to feel it in some
other sense and we can do that with all
kinds of things these are kind of like
what Jay Walker was calling ESP
extrasensory perceptions or electronic
sensory perceptions where we're actually
just trying to perceive things it
ourselves in ways that we could normally
and wearing you know cochlear plants and
contact lenses that these are actually
except in that same direction so so if
you want to feel the acceleration of
earth week we can do that somebody else
right hi what would you suggest to
physicians who are recalcitrant to the
idea of patients bringing in their own
data sets I mean how can we encourage
the doctors to take advantage of the
patient as an asset and not just reject
them out of hand but I don't know i'm
not i don't know what the doctors are
resisting really but maybe Gary well we
have had a lot of those conversations in
some of our meetups because there's md's
come and I think what I noticed what I
learned from watching those
conversations is that not all doctors
are alike and doctors are embedded in
systems and the systems are more or less
friendly to that sort of thing I do
think so there's a lot of work to be
done there and I think there are doctors
who are you know in our community who
are doing some of that work I do think
it helps to get the big picture though
because a lot of medicine is based kind
of on a storehouse of medical
information and there's a lot of
investment in making that storehouse
more efficient but there's a there's
also a way in which that storehouse of
information is rapidly becoming obsolete
or sort of buried in other
information a blood pressure
measurements a really good example so
you just have this case of sort of
medical data that is supposed to be
valid being swamped by other data and
also we have this image this mental
model that data is sort of like raw when
it's with the patient and then it gets
sort of validated and then it's finally
in a medical record and it's that's when
its best but what people are learning
obviously when they look at their
medical records is actually the data is
most valid when it's in a context and ie
when it's the person's data and it
actually loses validity often as it's
aggregated into these formal structures
so I mean having that big picture helps
at least outline the landscape that
doctors will be part of pretty soon and
and self-reported data actually so I
know a lot of physicians are and a lot
of people in the healthcare would
research in general are very suspicious
of self-reported data but I can point
you to the research that shows
self-reported data is is as accurate as
physician reported data so it's it's
it's really just a certain amount of x
and I think to the whole idea of data
coming from a different source god
forbid the patient somebody else right
there oh sorry
I hear you said all right yeah yep so
just a common a physician date so it
depends how the data comes in so for
example a glucometer which measures
blood glucose at different times of day
physicians would love that kind of data
the person brings it in the nurse or
another staff member sort of clicks it
in and you get a nice graph graphing
sort of time and means and averages of
the data and so physicians like that
kind of stuff because it's clean
relatively clean data it's something
that can result in not too much dialogue
or time so it's all about time now in
physicians offices so the data is easy
fast quick and help inform decision
making positions like it physicians I
think get worried about sort of noisy
type of data i think that takes a lot of
time okay what do you wouldn't you guys
have any comment on noisy data like data
that is just kind of a lot of junk in it
well yes and this is their skills in
collecting data and and lots of maybe
the talks among the user groups is
talking about how to collect better data
clean data and what to do with the data
and this is again a skill set a toolset
that we don't really have right now we
don't have really good drag and drop
statistical analysis tools you get a lot
of data and to do something meaningful
with it to extract out some kind of
pattern in a kind of reliable way is
actually very difficult right now
requires a certain level expertise in
the way that maybe I'm doing typesetting
was before desktop publishing came along
you know and it was or photography it
took it took a really kind of
specialized set of skills but they
became through the use of tools it
became commonplace it became something
they teach in grade school kerning fonts
and all this kind of stuff and I think
uh I think the same thing can happen
when people started working with big
data and they're required to that will
some people will gain a lot more
familiarity with some aspects of that
that's as part of the basic literacy
that will require for uh for dealing
with things and and I and I think uh the
noisy data is a problem but that's a
skill in terms of overcoming what you do
about it is
that I think people learn to do what can
I say one more thing about that is that
it's a quote from somebody Robin borough
who participates in a lot of our meetups
in the Bay Area he said you know it's
very very hard to do science and make
scientific discoveries but it's also
very hard not to learn something making
observations and analyzing them you know
and in a sense I think we're at the at
the amazingness that you always learn
something when you make these
observations and get these numbers about
yourself well listen I want to thank you
guys for catalyzing this community for
bringing this community together Gary
you're writing a book on it which is due
out soon I won't put a number or the
next thing but really you guys have you
guys have created a movement and helped
bring this forward so thank you so much
thanks for having us yeah thank you